A couple more points about generative
models, they are pretty straightforward.
First of all,
we've been doing the two class case.
Right?
You're either a skin or not skin.
Well, suppose I've got a bunch
of classes, c sub i, and
I've got a measurement, x.
Which c should I choose?
It's written here in green, c star.
So, very simply, I'm going to take the
category that maximizes p of c given x.
That is,
which category is most likely given x?
Okay, that makes some sense, well,
but I don't have that directly, so
in order to do that, I use
the likelihood times the, what's p of c?
That's our prior.
Okay, so I have to have my prior.
So, basically in generative models,
as you add a new, category, you
just need to build a likelihood model
and you need a prior model and that will
allow you to compare, one category to
the next in, in deciding a new label.
The other thing is, you remember before,
we were drawing these,
histograms to represent those,
those probability distributions?
Well, normally, what you want is a nice,
continuous generative model,
so what you need is
a likelihood density.
Okay?
So you don't just have a history,
I mean you actually want a density.
And remember, it's likelihood,
so it's p of x given c.
Not p of c given x.
That we get from Bayes' rule.
All right?
So typically we represent those
likelihoods using some parametric form.
Here it's written as a,
a mixture of Gaussians, right?
So here, this particular class 2,
and see it says p of x, given c 2?
That's its likelihood.
This is one little Gaussian lump.
And we do that because we said oh,
that looks you know, may,
maybe most of the distribution of those
pixel values is actually like that.
But over here for class 1,
you see that we've got two humps.
Okay?
And that's just a mixture of Gaussians.
And it's pretty,
it's not too difficult to estimate
a mixture of Gaussians from
a modest amount of data.
One, so one of the reasons to use these
kinds of parameterized distributions is
it allows you to use much less
data in order to fit your density.
So some of you might ask,
well wait a minute.
Why am I doing this whole
continuous fitting,
why not just use some like k-nearest
neighbor or Parzen window method or
something else that you
learned in probability class?
Megan is not going to remember that
question so I'm not going to ask her.
Never mind.
So why won't you do that?
Well, you actually, you might do that.
If you've got a lot of data, you might
actually try to do some histogram
KNN based method of
estimating your density.
But, you would really need lots and
lots of data.
Sort of everywhere that you're likely
to get a point, because you need
the densities pretty much everywhere
you're likely to get a data point.
And in some sense the whole
point of generative models is
to be able to use a modest
amount of data so the reason to
use the parameterized thing is
that you don't need a lot of data.
Okay?
It allows you to generate a model
that you can use for each category.